all right so we've been absent for quite
some time a lot of you have questions
you guys want to know what's changed
what's happened
and you're probably wondering where it
preaches and a lot of you've been
wondering like you guys broken up and
[ __ ]
and that's part of the reason uh why
we're doing today's video
uh preach uh is here hey what up
[ __ ] you thought it was about
you
here
i'm pretty sure they're pissed off right
now oh you [ __ ] like
[ __ ] watch them drop in the dms if you
like all that they've been mad
but you know what the thing is i'm not
going to talk for you i'm not going to
be like well you know this is what
uh is going on with abba i'm just going
to yo he's on a break
yeah it's all right yeah yeah it's not
right it's interesting but it's okay
isn't that what you said
i only know that sunk is using it not
because i hear five but it's
okay yeah so a lot of people were like
why didn't you guys warn us to bounce
with you i didn't even know
we were taking a break what ended up
happening was one day i just didn't want
to make a video
and then and then the next day came and
i didn't want to make a video
and then the day after that came and i
did one and then next thing i know four
or five weeks
and it wasn't like a conscious decision
to be like we're going to take two
months off we didn't know how long it
was going to last
we didn't know we were going to do it it
just kind of happened
i was ready for a break how are you yeah
i just
that just needed a less a lesser break
than you because
you do a lot of work right
you do a lot of the editing a lot of
[ __ ] like that so
and it's it's it's i was like yeah
i'd rather you take a break or two
months and you don't tell me when you're
gonna come back and you come back when
it's back on
me i was already trying to do this thing
then you don't take a break
and you never wanna [ __ ] do videos
again you never wanna do videos you're
like you're fed up
you're done that's how burnout works
for those of you don't know a burnout
basically is you stopping
when it's too late yeah it's too late
take a break take a
little breather and that's pretty much
what happened so i'm like i was like
yeah
dude do you here's the thing like the
way my life kind of functions
sometimes i'm just not available to the
people in my life
and so when i get into a period like
that where i'm kind of just taking time
for myself and just taking it easy it
doesn't i don't factor in
telling all the people around me because
they're kind of used to it and i
certainly don't think of telling
strangers because even though you guys
are our fans and things like that i
don't
feel like i know you guys well enough
yet because a lot of you have only
showed up over the last year you know
what i'm saying
so i'm still getting adjusted so so i
will admit that it probably wasn't
great on my behalf but i'm also not the
type of person to announce a break
i've never done that on facebook i've
never done that to the people in my
personal life hey guys just letting you
know i'm going to be offline
for me disconnecting from the uh
interweb interwear
is kind of a natural process i just go
through at periods and it's
it's really weird that you know whenever
you look you know when you look at your
feed
yeah you see someone uh wow this is so
much
i'm taking a break don't you roll your
eyes don't you roll don't you roll your
if you don't
fine but don't you roll your eyes like
you're looking at the eyes oh just
uh if you see me tomorrow
it's because you made the list [ __ ]
just cut me off
it's cool yeah it's it's cool yeah you
know what i mean
it ain't that serious so announcing it
to me
announcing a break like that especially
social media it's
just it feels weird horny it feels weird
it's cool
it's not for me i wasn't burnt out i
could have kept going
i think i would have been final so if i
kept going i think
the thing is like we haven't i haven't
taken time off for four years
i tried i left the country and i just
kept working while i was gone i haven't
taken time off truly um
and over the last year we've had a lot
of momentum
and you might know when you're running
down a hill and you've got lots of
momentum
if you don't if you don't slow down
you're going to break your face you know
when you start running like this
yes no longer this is yeah and you start
worrying because you're like miss i
don't think i can stop i don't know how
i'm agreeing
you know what i mean like if you ever
try to roll the blade and you don't know
how to break
yeah that's scary i think for me and
especially
when you're going down a hill for
example and you're going that fast
you have to start moving around all the
pieces of terrain because you're worried
everything is going to kill you
so for me it was just like an
opportunity for me to stop
take a breath and it just so happened
that i wanted to take many more breaths
and it was good it was good i just took
it easy i didn't even do much
i played some video games which i
haven't done in years and you know it's
also kind of
cool to know that i'm not too tied to
this
online world to youtube you know like if
i was to not have it tomorrow i know i
wouldn't fall apart you know
and it's just good to kind of keep
yourself in check and to remind yourself
that you're still just a person
who has really regular needs and it's
also like when we grew up
you know sometimes you just don't see
people for years and there's no internet
to be able to check in on everyone right
you're right you know like i'm kind of
used to that
i'm used to that idea of not always
being able to check in
on people and just understand sometimes
people are absent you know i had the a i
was at the age where i had a pager yeah
if i didn't find a pay phone or i didn't
have a quarter yeah you're gonna have to
wait till i get home
yeah yeah and if my mom on the phone
i'll talk to you tomorrow
what's that [ __ ] you saying yesterday
cause yeah yeah
yeah so that's what i'm kind of used to
so it's just an adjustment period for us
to also learn
how to better handle that so in the
future i'll try to kind of keep you guys
more in that loop but it also feels
weird for me to let you guys in so
i'm gonna be outside of yourself though
because i think
when we make this kind of content and
we're asking for this kind of engagement
on their part
we are kind of agreeing to a cert a form
of relationship whether we like it or
not
fair you know so yeah i just think
there's a
middle ground that we can maybe find
even if it makes us a little bit
uncomfortable i am mad at you
yeah i ain't mad at you that's what i'm
i'm thinking in my head yeah yeah yeah i
see which is
trying to see it from their perspective
and that's the thing like they like
before i'm before doing this [ __ ] yeah
i'm not really
following people yeah i mean now now i
am but before i wasn't so
i'm and because because of some things
that i found really weird at some point
they're gonna over share now i'm gonna
watch a video i'm gonna be like
too much information i feel like this is
too much i shouldn't be watching this
like i did a live
where we're talking about like the exes
what's going on
closure yeah yeah and sometimes
i was like oh i feel like i shouldn't be
here listening to this [ __ ]
i feel like i shouldn't be here
listening to this [ __ ] like oh why am i
listening to why
why am i a witness of this why are you
telling me all this stuff so
yes yeah i get what you're saying yeah
what
yeah it's interesting show me a picture
of your wife people feel like
being online all the time is bad for you
mentally right
yes i get that yeah but then the absence
of someone online also strikes them as
being really bad for your health
huge wolf is weird it feels weird for me
to tell them that we're on a break
when i wouldn't tell people in my
personal life that i'm necessarily on a
break
you did what i'm saying rough i didn't
tell my girl she's like she's like so
what's going on
i don't know move on so why am i gonna
tell you
and she's like you don't know what's
going on listen babe ah
it is easy is whatever it is
so maybe it's something i have to work
on who knows i don't know i'll take time
to think about it
but i just wanted to let you guys know i
don't think you're necessarily being
crazy
just know true i am how i am and it's
not necessarily the best
but you guys don't have to worry all
right don't ever think that i'm
going through something mentally so bad
that i'm going to start to
cut my you guys don't have to worry
about oh yeah someone said also i think
um
what hey why would you guys take a break
right now
it's really a hot time to be making
content and growing your brand
you know i don't want to be a slave
to the content you know what i mean
yeah yeah i don't want to i'm
here here's the thing oh it's hot i have
to talk about it
i don't care about winning that much
all right listen i already won after i
make 50k a year
i'm chilling like i really don't need to
make that much money
i don't need to be that i'm not i know
like in the western world we're really
axed on success and
hustle all the time i like to take
things easy i like to sit on a park
bench and
chill out i like to hang out my friends
for the day
i'm taking it easy i'm not so driven by
success um
what i can still sit on the bench with a
million in my pockets i am not mad at
you
hey hey b huh but all this to say
it's not it's not i'm on things that are
important to me making lots of money is
not up there making
being super it's not up there i enjoy it
and i enjoy making content but it
doesn't matter to me
that much so yeah
i think knowing that i just want to keep
making stuff when i feel like it and if
there's a time where i don't then i will
stop um
and if that sounds to you guys like a
betrayal or it's unfair
listen you guys are only going to enjoy
this content so long as we enjoy making
it
so this is kind of the agreement that we
have
is it a little flimsy maybe
but at least it'll stay authentic and at
least i can be honest with you
so yeah i mean you're honest in a
different kind of way
what do you mean there's different ways
of being honest
and being honest is you know it would be
to tell them what's going on
but being honest with them is actually
making content that you enjoy you're not
faking it
that's another way of being honest yeah
so
yeah teach your own everybody got their
their perception of what honesty is
how you can achieve honesty and that's
one of them like you can either like
tell everything about your life and
you're being really honest and sometimes
it's going to be really cringy because
people went over that or you're just
going to be hey
this is the content i mean there you go
i like that boom then then you're honest
with the work that you do
yeah or whatever that's me yeah all
right well
i think that's pretty much our thoughts
on this but yeah if you guys want to
leave us your feedback
tell us what you think we should have
done better or done worse whatever may
whatever it is
let us know in the comments below we
always go ahead don't mind hearing i'm
not going to listen but go ahead
i'll take her i'll give it a good read
um well yeah
i feel great been feeling great i've
never stopped feeling good
and i think preach feels the same way so
for all that you guys that worried
you guys have nothing to worry about
[Music]
you